Wisecrack Michael here. And the early days of the 21st century,
Travis Scott was just a kid in Houston who loved happy meals.
Face masks were reserved mostly for hospitals in Halloween and adult swim was
just a late night block of programming that showed cartoons aimed at, uh,
mellow adults rather than Caprice on fuel children. Then these guys came along,
mixing their love of public access,
television and underground art with absurdism and cultural commentary.
Their comedy was equal parts, awkwardness, and horror.
And while they started with obscure shows that aired at four in the morning,
they've now become legit celebrities,
appearing in major films and television and taking their talents into other
fields like pop music and artisanal wine-making along the way they transformed
the sensibility of adult swim and along with it modern comedy.
So how has an obscure comedy duo gone on to have such a massive impact across
popular culture and how have they stayed true to their roots in the process?
Did Tim and Eric take on these soul sucking entertainment industry?
And when let's find out in this wisecrack edition on the philosophy of Tim and
Eric, okay,
I want to take a break from talking about one awesome show to talk about an
awesome podcast, which is wisecracks culture bench. So hosted by me,
along with Alec and Serby,
and it's where we breakdown everything happening in the cultural zeitgeists,
whether that be we're new developments in online,
dating how your boomer parents ruined your life for how in the hell people were
playing sports inside of a bubble.
The link to this podcast is in the description of this video. So maybe pause,
click that subscribe. And when you do subscribe, we would love it.
If you would give us a review, check it out every other Wednesday,
link in the description. Now back to the show, first,
a quick rundown on the duo. After meeting in film school,
Tim Heidecker and Eric Wareheim took advantage of the gear Eric was using for
his bar mitzvah videography business to film comedy sketches.
Eventually they sent a DVD to Bob Odenkirk, also known as attorney salt Goodman,
who became an early champion of their work.
This led to their first adult swim show. Tom goes to the mayor,
lasting two seasons adult swim calls, the animated series.
One of the most polarizing shows they've ever made.
We're going to need at least 10,000 of your finest traps,
whatever it takes to keep those kids safe.
Wild irreverence, and unabashedly, dark humor.
It paved the way for their mature work, Tim and Eric. Awesome show. Great job.
Good job.
And this is what really took them from obscure animation anarchists to legit
cult heroes building on many of the same themes and characters.
Awesome show created an entire alternate reality of surreal lo-fi television.
Taking the aesthetics of a public access show and tossing an actors found on
Craigslist.
It feels like an awkward Thanksgiving dinner with your aunt and uncle who you
suspect might actually already be dead.
So how did two comedians who don't even tell jokes worm their way into the
mainstream?
Fine. Mom makes me take my nips. Cause my nips gets bloody when the skin rips,
cause I wear a tight shirt that chase my nips, nobody likes bloody nips.
One way we can understand it is via the tradition of outsider art.
This term is used to describe art created by people outside of the mainstream
tradition and often with no formal training.
Often these artists create work that feels like it's from.
Another world.
There's also a tradition of outsider.
Art created by both children and folks with mental disabilities.
Some famous examples in visual art are Henry Dodger,
a janitor whose work was discovered by his landlord after he died.
And Vivian Maier,
a street photographer whose work was also found after her death.
And it's not a stretch to include Tim and Eric in this tradition to the lucky
for us, we didn't have to wait for their passing to discover their work.
They began creating comedy in Philadelphia,
outside the traditional power centers of LA and New York.
And rather than working their way up the ranks from the inside,
they simply reached out to one of their comedy heroes and got a show mate with
no previous TV experience. And since then,
their work has largely been broadcast on adult swim,
which lies on the fringes of mainstream culture.
While they did attend at film school,
it's clear that they learn more from low quality public access TV than they did
from classic cinema.
They've also relied on the power of Craigslist to find mostly older performers
living on the margins of the entertainment industry.
One of their regular singer and puppeteer David Leba Hart is a legitimate
outsider artist in his own right?
Having spent years as a street performer before becoming a staple on awesome
show,
they even tried to develop a television series with the dark Prince of outsider,
cinema himself, Tommy Wiseau.
This outsider status is important to their work because it allows them to
satirize and explore media culture from a true critical distance with no
responsibility or desire to fatefully emulate mainstream television.
And it's clear that their artistic influences,
which are more David Lynch and Wolf man Jack than Adam Sandler and Chevy chase
are outside the realm of traditional sketch comedy.
Most traditional comedic television has largely pacifying effect on the viewer,
making us feel good without provoking any difficult questions or emotions,
whether it's a political sketch on SNL that makes most of its audience not in
semi snug agreement or an episode of the good place that makes us smile because
we also believe in the eternal magic of friendship.
Most comedic TV exists to make us feel comfortable and safe.
And if these types of shows are a weighted blanket,
making us feel safe and warm,
then Tim and Eric awesome show is like a raccoon that's snorted crystal meth
broke into your bedroom and figured out a place Slayer on iTunes.
Happy birthday spray. I'm disappointed in you in honey, take this.
Gotcha.
And which a couple and announces they're divorced to their heartbroken children.
And then they reveal why mom is leaving for a younger and more handsome man who
burglarized to their house last week.
Your mommy's in love with a burglar and dad is going to live on the streets for
a while. It's super uncomfortable.
So how did Tim and Eric break the tension and infuse some comedy?
Perfect.
Are we coming to here.
Then?
Usually dark scenario is hilariously undercut by something simple and childish
or consider Fortin with will a sketch model. After a fun segment,
that slowly becomes a disturbing recollection of someone's own childhood.
Don't flush them. Try likes.
I want you to leave those logs in there for me to inspect.
Work is often uncomfortable to watch even for seasoned fans.
Excuse me. When I think about my father,
sometimes there is an involuntary release from here.
Personally. I still cover my eyes and season five,
as they get their eyes eaten out by crows while an Irish,
Dwight Truett warns them about the dark man.
Man power.
At moments like this,
they lean heavy into the horror genre to confuse our brains comedy receptors.
Unlike the pacifying and affirming nature of so much mainstream comedy,
Tim and Eric's work can feel antagonistic as if they are pushing the audience to
see how much we can take.
They take existing cultural norms and either ignore them or subvert them beyond
recognition.
Having a going out of business.
Eric also take aim at consumer culture,
finding bizarre new ways to explore our dysfunctional relationship with and
desire for material goods.
It's got one 97, 99, 69 cheap.
Work is less political than anthropological diving into the world of advertising
and marketing so they can slowly pull it apart from the inside out as critic
Frank wan describes it.
What's most striking about the awesome show is not the comprehensiveness of its
critique, but its gentleness.
The illusions of Congress are not stabbed to death so much is silently stripped
bare, take their commercial for the jammer.
A children's toy based on the Bobbitt that has no discernible function other
than destroying the minds of kids and filling them with the seemingly insatiable
desire for an utterly useless thing.
Monitor your friends, progress three bumpin.
It's straight.
Funny until you step back and reflect on the way much of our media exists to
sell it. We don't need, but nonetheless we lust after it like an annuity dog,
let loose at a thick leg convention as journalists Keith, a Spencer put it,
the brilliance lies and how Tim and Eric take the signs and signifiers of late
capitalist consumption and stretch them until they are unidentifiable.
It's an outrageous satire of consumerist excess.
And this critique of consumerism hits so hard because again,
it's created by outsiders who haven't bought into this culture,
but just like what happened with everything from punk rock to video games to
dipping your pizza and ranch things that start as counter-cultural and outside
the mainstream are eventually co-opted by those in power,
which is why your pastor Richard's favorite band is green day.
The quarterback of your high school football team has his own Twitch stream and
high-end pizza shops offer housemate artisinal ranch for an extra one 50 and
awesome show is no exception to the ranch covered rule. First,
Tim and Eric attracted some top-notch comedy talent,
including cameos from Paul Rudd,
Zach Galifianakis will Farrell and Ted Danson.
Then clinically middlebrow shows like Saturday night live started to adopt their
awkward and uncomfortable. In fact,
SNL both produced a sketch that arguably ripped off at Tim and Eric sketch and
aired sketches like this, which clearly crib,
the comedic aesthetics of Tim and Eric down to the cadence of Kristen Wiggs
delivered.
I'm taking myself a hot air balloon ride.
Of course the main difference is that here,
the antagonism of an actual awesome show sketch is treated for a more
commercially palatable, awkward.
I've touched a clown. Now I'm going to jail.
Same influence with antagonism traded for awkwardness and a show like
Portlandia,
which is basically for people who love the absurdity of awesome show,
but also appreciate the safety and comfort of a Subaru Outback. For example,
Fred Armisen and Carrie Brownstein have their ongoing fanciful gender mending
romance story and comparison.
Tim and Eric have this recurring sketch about the dysfunctional relationship
between Carol and Mr. Henderson.
Get me rock hard. Thank you. I just had my hair cut,
which eventually.
Ends with Henderson being half guillotined and dying.
Can you imagine getting your head cut off one of these Gies?
Well, Carol is a radically negative by as nurse.
Whoa, you are one big weird eggplant.
Romance stuff.
Generally take any comedy that years more towards awkward and absurd than it
does.
Traditionally funny send some of its juices to a genetics lab and it's bound to
come back at least 65% Tim and Eric and its ancestry.
They've also had a more direct influence on shaping modern comedy with their
absolutely productions,
which is responsible for everything from the late night absurdism of the Eric
Andre show to the Canadian business school wisdom of Nathan for you and so on.
Tim and Eric have used their success as outsiders working on the inside of the
entertainment industry to bring a whole bunch of other weird unlikely comedy
stars. Along with them.
It's like they somehow got seats in first class and slowly all their dirt bag
friends from coach up there with them.
Pancakes couldn't kill me because I was already dead.
Now influencing other television shows and comedians is one thing,
but these two beef boys might've had their biggest influence on his space,
not normally kind to avant-garde and counter-cultural artists,
corporate advertising.
Have your lighting servant to get a GE link light bulb for only 1497.
That's less than what I tip the guy who tips people for me.
Even if many folks will tragically never watch an episode of awesome show or
beef house.
Anyone who's regularly watched American television in the past decade has seen a
commercial either created by or heavily influenced by Tim and Eric. For example,
if you liked me,
if slathered a stick of old spice under your dank underarms every morning for
the past 10 years after Terry crews threatened you, how was it?
You almost definitely were influenced by the advertising of Tim and Eric,
but Arctic for smelling armpits aside. Isn't it kind of weird.
The two outsider artists who largely cut their teeth by securing the sick
emptiness of consumer culture.
They've gone on to make ads for the likes of Google GoDaddy boost mobile GE,
and BRBO presumably all aimed at selling you. You don't need maybe,
but we are willing to suspend judgment.
There might be something even deeper going on here.
Now at first it might seem bizarre if not genuinely disappointing that the guys
behind the jammer would become admin in layman's terms.
This is usually called selling out like Matthew McConaughey using his
hypnotizing, Texas drawl, the cellular Lincoln SUV or Travis Scott,
letting you know that if you buy as McDonald's meal and accompanying $80 chicken
McNugget pillow, that things will once and for all truly be lit. So Howard,
Tim and Eric able to work in the world of advertising without embracing the type
of hollow consumerism. They've always hated in 2008,
Heidecker said in an interview, we both despise advertising and marketing.
You can't avoid it. And it's always so inane.
I find that we're constantly being treated like children,
even with other forms of media. And in the very same year,
they won a Webby for their absolute vodka ad, told them three parts.
The ad featuring Zach Galifianakis seems to retain a lot of Tim and Eric
signature style, weird wigs, mundane conversations, turning violent,
uncomfortable sexual energy,
all culminating in a full-scale emotional breakdown,
the actual endorsement for absolute doesn't come until the third installment of
an almost 15 minute long.
Commercial. Do you guys like absolute?
I have.
That. And it sounds about as genuine as Tom Selleck,
trying to get your grandparents to reverse mortgage their condoms.
It's just alone.
This ad clearly isn't a slimy as a lot of celebrity commercials and it doesn't
sacrifice Tim and Eric signature aesthetic, but is it doing anything subversive?
Eric had this to say in an interview with the believer we wanted to work with
the comedian, Zach Galifianakis, who we love,
we were also allowed to do anything. We wanted absolute head approach Zack,
and they were basically paying all of us to make an anti ad.
How could we have said no,
of course you could argue that this ad is mostly about giving absolute some
underground cultural cred and ensuring potential consumers that they're down
with Tim and Eric's vibe.
But an example of the duo using a commercial deal to be slightly more subversive
is their ad for Totonno's pizza rolls.
If they're absolute ad tries to avoid reminding you,
you're watching a commercial by barely mentioning the product.
This one goes the opposite route using a near constant repetition of the word
Totonno's and a sort of punk rock song about pizza, right?
Pizza rolls.
Virtual feels like a knowing,
wink to those who who'd accused them of losing their punk rock credibility.
At one point, Hardrock, Joe even tells us.
Can keep all that corporate BS arm until punk pizza
rolls with Tony chinos.
So is this technically an advertisement for low quality pizza nuggets? Sure.
But is it doing anything to earnestly sell a product? No.
Really. Hi, I'm Tennessee, a pizza freak and I have a secret.
I am pizza Tortino's boy.
If anything,
it grows increasingly disturbing and makes you wonder if the Totonno's lifestyle
is code for some sort of process to mozzarella fueled sex school.
If it weren't made explicit at the end of the ad,
you could be forgiven for assuming this wasn't a commercial at all,
but a sketch using a gross snack is fodder for absurdity.
So.
On a charitable reading,
it seems that Tim and Eric are at times able to use advertising to subvert the
fundamental expectations of the influencer economy.
Whereas Lincoln is using the star of failure to launch,
to sell luxury SUV's and McDonald's is using the Mozart of Auto-Tune to sell
fries and barbecue sauce.
Tim and Eric are at least using companies like absolute and total Tino's to make
weird comedy.
Tortino's Latinos, Latinos, Latinos, Latinos, Latinos.
Yeah. Yeah.
Our most generous. We could argue that in doing this,
they are performing the same type of satire they did with the jammer sketch,
except they were simply subbing out a fictional,
useless product for real useless products.
But as anyone who has seen Andy Warhol soup cans knows this wouldn't be the
first time that an underground artists performative critique of consumerism was
appropriated by the very culture it's set out to critique. Now,
does this actively support the idea that Tim and Eric are still outsider
artists? Not really.
As most outsider artists live in poverty or psychiatric facilities make almost
no money and rarely receive credit for their work and their lifetime.
So wouldn't it technically made Tim and Eric more punk rock.
If someone discovered a box full of comedy DVDs under their adult bunk beds
after they died in obscurity, maybe, but honestly,
we're glad that they've gotten to receive some praise and of course,
compensation for their work while they're still around to enjoy it. And in turn,
we're glad we've gotten this.
[Inaudible].
But what do you think wisecrack are Tim and Eric pushing the boundaries of
comedy as a critical art form?
Or are they just two dudes trying to retire on a pile of free vodka pizza rolls
and deodorant? Let us know what you think in the comments special,
thanks to our patrons for all your support.
And don't forget to smash that subscribe button.
Like it's a secret feature on the jammer and as always, thanks for watching.
[Inaudible].